hello everybody it's Joe the locksmith
in this video we're working on a
2019 on the cord push to start all the
keys are
lost using the atile IM 608 Pro to and
the universal I key first we'll generate
the key we'll go to Universal key
accept universal key generation
North
America
Honda type by model
Accord it's a
2019 yes this is the
selection I'm going to generate
Universal key
okay the button type is different but
it's okay we're going to
continue
for
h okay Universal key generation is
completed press
complete okay let's back out of
here yes exit let's go to
immo
accept Okay let's go to
Honda big fing is
today
manual
select so
cord smart key push to stop
okay control
unit keyless
system is the ignition turned on by
pressing stop button twice one two no it
is not say no press and hold the stop up
press and hold it
[Music]
down okay car is on can release just
going to turn the Ste whe
[Music]
here
all right there we
are say
Okay looks like we're going to have to
add extra power to the vehicle the
voltage is going low
all right I'm just going to pause it
here and add extra
power okay we now have extra
power car is on we're going to choose
all keys
lost
okay okay we have the key in the
car just going to let's turn the
ignition off
here I'm going to say no press and hold
the stop
[Music]
button okay car is now on
release
[Music]
okay you just want to do one
key okay ignition switch off I'm just
going to turn it
off ignition switch on press it two
times one
[Music]
two
okay ignition switch is on looks like
it's hung up but the key is
registered let's just cancel this
here yeah exit the
function yeah let's test out the key
turn it on
unlock lock
unlock keep again
here and let's try to start it
off little low on power but there she
goes all right there we have it a 2019
Honda Accord push to start all small
keys lost we use the alltile IM 608 Pro
2 and the universal I key thank you for
watching have a great day